Now that we've completed making
our prototype we'll want to gather
feedback using Envision.
There are two methods for
gathering feedback on your designs.
First I previously
mentioned the share link.
Share links are a great way to
gather feedback on your project.
You can also generate specific share
links that only display specific screens
in your project if your trying
to obtain targeted feedback.
Another way to gather feedback
is through a live share meeting.
Live share meetings are instant meetings
where you can share your designs with
unlimited participants
in a live meeting.
The meeting is free, and is similar
to a GoToMeeting, WebEx, join.me or
Google Hangout meeting.
In live share meetings, you can see
all participant cursors on screen.
You can activate a drawing mode, where
everyone can draw over your designs.
Participants of your meeting can
also leave contextual comments,
which get saved instantly,
just like they would when viewing and
commenting on a share link.